en comme chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mercredi 29 septembre à
rien ne va plus entre le mali et la
france finit le langage diplomatique
entre les deux pays en cause le retrait
des soldats de l'opération barquettes du
sel une décision qualifiée d' abandon en
plein vol par le gouvernement malien
paris qui doit faire face à une autre
affaire très délicate l'agencé française
de développement est accusé d'avoir
fourni des armes des militaires à
l'origine d'exécution au sahel les
détails de cette enquête dans un instant
finir également aux états unis où le
spectre d'un nouveau choc d'ordre se
profile le congrès a jusqu'à demain soir
minuit pour approuver un nouveau budget
du gouvernement fédéral s'il veut éviter
que les fonds ne soient soudainement
coupé un test crucial pour le président
américain joe biden qui pourrait payer
ses choix en matière de politique
étrangère
au sommaire à 21h notre rubrique qu'en
pensent les français alors que les
fortes hausses de tarifs de gaz et
d'électricité inquiètent la question de
la transition énergétique monte en
puissance à sept mois de la
présidentielle
certains comme les verts appellent à la
multiplication du recours aux éoliennes
mais sur le terrain qu'en pense vraiment
la population concernée nous sommes
allés à la rencontre des habitants de
tignes et dans le maine et loire qui ont
obtenu gain de cause dans leur lutte
contre les éoliennes se trouvant devant
chez eux
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ses titres
petit détour vers la porte de la
villette dans le nord de paris les
habitants manifestent ce soir ils
expriment leur colère après le
déplacement de toxicomanes aux portes de
ce département de la seine saint denis
ils protestent contre la décision
construire un mur beauchamp un tunnel
menant de pente à un pari même
indignation d'une trentaine des lieux
qui interpellent le premier ministre et
de l'ongle de prendre les mesures tout
ça pour plaire
cela a été fait sans aucune concertation
sans aucune information sans aucune
préparation si ce n'est dans la
précipitation une conséquence directe de
ce déménagement la construction d'un mur
soit disant pour protéger les comptines
oiseaux des continents il faut trouver
une solution une solution pérenne une
solution qui soit humaine à ce problème
qui mine le nord et l'est parisien
depuis plus de dix ans le conan de la
consommation du crack dans notre l'est
parisien c'est l'état qui doit qui est
compétent pour régler cela et au lieu de
le faire mesdames messieurs dans le
cadre d'une approche sanitaire social
médical
c'est le ministre de l'intérieur qui
s'en occupe c'est une approche
sécuritaire uniquement sécuritaire
soigner les ce sont des êtres humains au
complet détresse il faut leur proposer
un parcours thérapeutique médicale
sociale et on retrouve sur place
stéphanie benoît porte parole du
collectif 93 anticraft qui a évidemment
participer à cette manifestation ce soir
bonsoir
stéphanie benoit merci d'être avec nous
on vient de le voir en ces élus qui
demandent un entretien notamment en
urgence au premier ministre clairement
qu'attendez-vous des services de l'état
alors l'heure on a appris aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs qu'une réunion devait se
tenir demain avec des membres de l'état
la ville de paris le préfet de police et
le préfet de paris
malheureusement les élus du 93 et
notamment les maires de pantin et
d'aubervilliers n'ont pas été consultés
n'ont pas été conviés
donc on regrette on le regrette
fortement et amèrement eux
nous on attend que c'est ces réunions
qu'elle débouche sur une réelle solution
pérenne une prise en charge sanitaire et
sociale de ces de ces toxicomanes qui ne
peuvent plus errer dans les rues comme
ça et qu'ils ne peuvent plus être subir
des énièmes le déplacement comme comme
ça a été encore le cas vendredi alors
stéphanie benoit pour bien qu'on
comprenne un expliquez-nous d'ailleurs
ce que vous avez derrière vous ce fameux
mur le mur surnommé le mur de la honte
expliquez-nous votre quotidien le
quotidien des habitants
que vous représentez ce soir
alors le quotidien des habitants
aujourd'hui on compose avec une arrivée
de nouveaux visages de toxicomanes on en
connaissait déjà dans le quartier
aujourd'hui on compose avec des nouveaux
qui ne nous connaissent pas avec
lesquels on n'ait pas été apprivoisés
foncez pas apprivoiser si j'ose dire
ainsi
aujourd'hui on doit composer avec leur
toxicomanie avec
leur addiction et là où ça les entraîne
on se retrouve à confrontée à des scènes
de violence
certaines font font font des témoignages
en précisant qu'elles ont été victimes
de le gifle de coups de poings de vols
déjà même déjà dès vendredi dès leur
arrivée
ce mur que j'ai derrière moi lui alors
il à la seule et unique symbolique de de
vouloir essayer de diviser encore un peu
plus le 93 du territoire parisien en
aucun cas ils empêchent comme l'a évoqué
monsieur darmanin de 2,2 de faire passer
les deux les toxicomanes sur le 93
puisque dans ce cas là la porte de la
villette aurait dû dans ce cas être être
murée et donc les toxicomanes
effectivement viennent sur sur nos
secteurs
s'installe dans nos goûts nos cages
d'escaliers on commence à apprendre des
vols de voitures de différentes
violences et incivilités qui sont liées
à ces toxicomanes clairement ce mur
aussi un peu long des stands bien ça
empêche aussi beaucoup de riverains qui
faisait peut-être aller retour notamment
à vélo pour éviter les gros bouchons par
de la chapelle de de circuler
aujourd'hui c'est évidemment un handicap
pour les personnes du quartier on
imagine
alors effectivement certains certains
pans tinois essentiellement puisque le
mur est construit sur sur la ville de
pantin certain franck lions à utiliser
ce utilisait ce passage pour se
raccourcir le trajet se dirige en
direction de la porte de la villette bon
ben maintenant ils sont obligés de
l'utiliser l'avenue jean jaurès et la
porte de la villette directement c'est
vrai que c'est regrettable parce que du
coup ça les oblige à
revoir leur itinéraire nous aussi en
tant qu albertivillariens obligés de
revoir nos itinéraires parce que là où
sont implantées désormais les
toxicomanes c'est à ciel ouvert s'est il
ya aucune fermeture et ils vont viennent
comme ils veulent on les retrouve à se
battre sur les trottoirs donc des
trottoirs qui sont normalement utilisés
par les riverains de pantin et
d'aubervilliers pour se rendre au métro
on comprend c'est que c'est un problème
sans fin puisque ça fait des années que
ça dure dans le 19e avant on a déplacé
donc ce problème faire chez vous alors
chacun évidemment il va de sa
proposition gérald darmanin qui décide
qui assure que cette situation serait
temporaire le garde des sceaux qui
déclarent travailler très sérieusement
sur la question épineuse du crack à
paris valérie pécresse ol qui veut des
centres de désintoxication clairement
vous avez encore toute confiance aux
autorités qu'elle abhorre qu'elle soit
alors c'est vrai que là aujourd'hui on
se demande qu'est ce qui bloque parce
que on a entendu dire que la région a
apporté son soutien financier on a
entendu dire que la ville de paris avait
trouvé des structures afin d'aider des
endroits pour pour développer ce genre
de structure et pourtant aujourd'hui on
voit pas d'issue on voyait ya il n'y a
rien qui se met en place il ya rien de
concret donc on se demande vraiment où l
élément bloquant qu'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a rien qui soit
proposée pour justement va prendre en
charge ces personnes et pour avoir été
mon contact avec deux d'entre eux la les
5 derniers jours
ça ça reste des humains qui disent eux
même avoir la nécessité de ce stylo les
les uns les autres
aujourd'hui on se pose aussi la question
et c'était bien le point voient égalité
10 789
1989 on imagine voilà que les habitants
de seine-saint-denis prennent ça comme
une forme d'humiliation tout simplement
pourquoi avoir choisi ce quartier
c'est ça a été justifiée par le
gouvernement par jal darmanin
alors le
le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
herman a évoqué effectivement qu'il n'y
avait pas de vivre dans ce quartier il
n'ya pas effectivement de riverains
directs sur le square de la porte de la
villette néanmoins il ya des riverains à
moins de 100 mètres donc c'est
complètement faux de dire qu'il n'y a
pas de riverains puisque en plus nous
sommes tous usagers de cet endroit pour
prendre à nos ados travail respectif
donc c'est vraiment cessé pris comme un
coup de poignard parce que on a
l'impression que les âmes qui vivent
derrière le périph n'existe pas aux yeux
du gouvernement et
et qu'on connaît déjà déjà beaucoup de
difficultés et on se dit que c'est
impossible qu on nous rajoute des
problèmes à ses difficultés lesquels on
essaie déjà de sortir la tête de l'eau
merci en tout cas et on m'appelle
injustement que le quartier des quatre
chemins étaient hôtels classés quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
un pour la petite information
ironique merci en tout cas vous
stéphanie benoit d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france pour ce
témoignage
et un mur de la honte comme beaucoup le
surnomment érigée sous l'impulsion dont
du ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin qui dans le même temps poursuit
sa lutte contre l'islam radical il
l'avait annoncé il y à deux jours des
procédures contre plusieurs associations
dans le cadre de la lutte contre le
séparatisme
le conseil des ministres a validé et
procédures ce matin la distribution de
deux associations était confirmée par le
porte parole du gouvernement écoutez
en cette période
marquée par
toujours des enjeux très fort en matière
de sécurité en matière de radicalisation
nous avons décidé ce matin en conseil
des ministres de prendre une mesure
importante une mesure forte une mesure
qui a été attendu car notre main ne
tremble pas quand il s'agit de défendre
la république face à ceux qui croient
pouvoir la faire plier ainsi ce matin
nous avons en conseil des ministres
décidé de dissoudre la ligue de défense
noire africaine qui avait encore
récemment tenté d'envahir la mairie de
val de reuil ainsi que l'association
nawa qui sous le prétexte de la
traduction faisait l'apologie du djihad
la république et ferme elle est solide
et elle le restera elle le restera
malgré ceux qui tentent de la faire
trembler elle le restera malgré ce
qu'ils cherchent à la bc et à l'accabler
à longueur de discours
et autres dossiers qui préoccupent part
il celui de l'annulation par l'australie
du contrat d'achat de sous marins
français
le ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian était auditionné
aujourd'hui au sénat sur les
conséquences de cette rupture de cet
accord le sénat qui n'a pas fermé la
porte à la création d'une commission d'
enquête sur cette affaire notre reporter
katia technique a suivi cette audition
dans son propos introductif le ministre
des affaires étrangères a évoqué cette
retrouver devant le fait accompli
qu'aucun signe avant coureur n'était
perceptible la france avait en effet
signé en 2010 est à partenariat
stratégique avec l'australie et le méga
contrat avec naval groupe s'inscrivaient
dans cette alliance est une première
phase du contrat avait même été exécuté
cet été l'australie selon lui n'a pas
remis le contrat en question anthony
blinken qui a rencontré jean yves le
drian avait tout aussi insisté sur la
nécessité de travailler ensemble
le 15 septembre la revue australienne
s'est même montré satisfait de la phase
1 cette trahison ne pouvait donc pas
être décelé selon jean yves le drian on
écoute ce qui est en jeu dans ce qu'il
faut bien qualifier de trahison vous
dites camoufler moi je les lis trahison
de rupture de confiance dans la relation
transatlantique et de confirmation du
spectaculaire degré de dépendance à
l'égard des états unis de l'australie et
du royaume uni c'est aussi la place
d'aidé européen dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui et cet enjeu est double
c'est d'abord le sens de nos alliances
end au partenariat c'est aussi et ce
n'est pas moins fondamentale la manière
dont nous choisissons de répondre en
fonction nous intérêt propre et de notre
lecture commune de la situation aux
tensions et aux menaces qui existent
aujourd'hui en particulier dans la zone
indo pacifique blocus est en fait le nom
d'une alliance militaire nouvelle
et d'un alignement sur une logique qui
systématisent la confrontation voire la
confrontation militaire logique qui aux
états unis s'est mis progressivement en
place depuis l'administration obama il
est donc urgent de renforcer encore
l'europe de la défense que nous
construisons pas à pas de façon concrète
et et pragmatique depuis maintenant
plusieurs années
il y va de notre sécurité et de notre
souveraineté et il a beaucoup été
question de stratégie indo pacifique
face aux ambitions chinoises qui selon
les sénateurs envoie des signaux
alarmants jean yves le drian a plaidé
pour une défense européenne
complémentaires à celles de l'otan mais
seront ils suivis par les états
européens la france at-elle encore
suffisamment d'influencé celle qui a été
mise de côté par la nouvelle alliance
etats unis grande bretagne australie
le ministre a expliqué devoir revoir
toutes ses relations avec l'australie
qui n'est plus un partenaire fiable pour
la france australie qui s'éloigne de
l'europe australie qui s'est intégrée
selon le ministre dans l'outil de
défense américain se plaçant dans une
dépendance aux états unis et comme les
australiens ont changé pour une
technologie plus offensive proposée par
les américains faut-il adapter notre
offre française en tout cas de nombreux
sénateurs de gauche souhaitent une
commission d' enquête pour comprendre
les raisons du plus grand échec
commercial de l'histoire de notre
industrie de défense
cérémonie national aux invalides
aujourd'hui en hommage à maxime blesse
conduire l'intervention au mali vendredi
dernier le caporal chef de 34 ans a été
élevé au grade de sergent claude tu mets
fait officier de la légion d'honneur en
présence d'emmanuel macro et de
plusieurs membres du gouvernement c'est
le 52e militaires français morts au
combat ou celle de puis 2013 et le sel
qui doit faire face désormais au
désengagement militaire français un
retrait des hommes de l'opération barkan
qualifié d' abandon en plein vol par le
gouvernement malien et c'est dans ce
contexte que l'agencé française de
développement dont l'objectif est
d'aider les pays pauvres est accusé de
dérive selon les médias à mediapart et
disclose par le biais d'une filiale elle
aurait fourni des armes des militaires
accusés d'exactions on sait justement
les explications des stèles farges
196,4 millions d'euros c'est le montant
du contrat décroché par expertise france
avec l'union européenne
expertise france est un établissement
public est liée à l'afd l'agencé
française de développement dans le cadre
de ce contrat l'établissement a livré du
matériel militaire aux pays du g5 sahel
le mali le niger le burkina faso le
tchad et la mauritanie mais selon une
enquête de dix close et de mediapart
certains soldats appartenant à ces
armées ont été accusés de violations de
droits humains par plusieurs ong et par
les nations unies en juillet 2020 les
ong human rights watch a par exemple
documenté l'exécution extrajudiciaire de
plusieurs centaines de personnes par les
soldats de la force conjointe un mois
plus tard la mission des nations unies
au mali a publié un rapport indiquant
que les forces du burkina faso se sont
rendus coupables d'au moins 50
exécutions sommaires quant aux forces de
sécurité de défense du mali les auteurs
du rapport les accuse d'avoir exécuté
94 personnes de façon arbitraire entre
avril et mai 2020 selon les deux médias
parmi le matériel fourni on retrouve des
blindés mais aussi des drones des gilets
pare-balles des systèmes de vision
nocturne ou encore des groupes
électrogènes disclose et mediapart ont
contacté expertise france pour l'agent
sa responsabilité je cite prend fin
lorsque la propriété des matériels et
transférés aux bénéficiaires elle
précise aussi que son soutien aux armes
et du g5 sahel est un soutien non
létales de son côté l'afd a fait savoir
aux deux médias qu'elle exerçait une
vigilance sur la façon dont ce matériel
est utilisé sans pour autant donner de
précisions sur les moyens à sa
disposition pour le vérifier la france
est extrêmement vigilante aux conditions
d'emploi et d'utilisation des matériels
et financements apportés aux pays du g5
sahel toujours est il que rien n'empêche
à ce jour les pays qui reçoivent ce
matériel de les transformer en arme
létale en adjoignant par exemple une
mitrailleuse un blindé de transport à ce
propos la sd se justifier la force
conjointe du g5 sahel a été créé afin
d'assurer la sécurité de la sous région
dans le but de favoriser un
développement économique et social
favorable aux populations pourtant la
situation semble se dégrader dans cette
zone en 2020 selon les chiffres de la
clède près de 2400 civils ont été tués
l'objectif de pacification de la région
voulue par la france et celui du g5 ça
elle semble à la lumière de cette
enquête loin d'être atteint alors cette
enquête pourrait talent attiser un peu
plus les tensions entre l'allemagne et
la france place à notre décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pourrons parler claude
blanche maison expert en relations
internationales à vos côtés adèle kerim
compte du goût me chercheur associé au
groupe affine de lips bonsoir monsieur
merci d'être avec nous également on
vient d'entendre un oncle agence
française de développement qui aurait
fourni selon mediapart notamment fourni
des armes des militaires accusés
d'exactions au sel c'est une enquête et
des faits qui vous semblent crédibles
adelkarim un condo remis
le rapport dit vrai et nous avons
constaté cela depuis très longtemps la
conséquence de cette vision centralisée
et étatiste de la mda ce qui concerne
l'aide au développement qui ne
correspond parfois pas aux besoins réels
des populations et l'efficacité de cette
aide la scène l'adaptation à une
situation de lutte contre le terrorisme
la conséquence directe de cela c'est la
vision de la lutte contre le terrorisme
mais uniquement centralisé sur l'aspect
militaire de cette lutte contre ce fléau
le droit de l'homme la bonne gouvernance
la démocratie ont été complètement mis
de côté et tout a été centralisé sur
l'âme et la solution de l'âme et quand
on voit
les gouvernements de cette zone 2 et 5
sur elle par exemple le tchad qui est
dirigé par un régime autoritaire où son
pouvoir est basé sur les piliers de
l'armée qui est
militarisée et à son service une armée
de répression
cette armée de répression qui ne
respectent pas les droits humains
indisciplinés qui n'est pas formé qu'on
utilise cette armée et qu'on aime cette
année pour ses soldats on les amène sur
le champ de lutte contre le terrorisme
est évidemment ces armes et se comporte
exactement comme il se comporte dans
leur propre pays c'est de cela que sept
rapports absolument raison et qu'il
fallait vraiment et urgemment à
réfléchir sur la façon de revoir cette
stratégie en prenant en compte aussi les
droits humains et la bonne gouvernance
maison c'est avec cette agence
ça se développe ment elle est le symbole
de la solidarité de la france dans le
monde c'est vrai que pour le grand
public on a du mal à y voir clair parce
que c est fait c'est un sale coup 1%
pour son image que kele vous votre
diagnostic quand vous entendez monsieur
s'exprimer comme ça est ce qu'il ya des
nuances à apporter il ya sûrement des
choses à revoir et améliorer sur le mode
de fonctionnement mais l' agence
française de développement ne craint pas
grand chose quant à sa réputation
d'abord pour des raisons historiques et
politiques il se trouve que l'ancêtre de
l' agence française de développement
c'est la caisse de financement de la
résistance fondé par le général de
gaulle en 1941 bien sûr ensuite ça a
beaucoup évolué puisque ensuite elle
s'est consacré comme vous l'avez dit à
la coopération avec l'afrique
essentiellement l'afrique francophone et
puis au fur et à mesure des années ses
compétences se sont élargies et se sont
élargies à l'ensemble de l'afrique puis
à l'asie puis à l'amérique latine se
sont élargies aussi à des sujets qui
étaient gérés auparavant directement par
le ministère de la coopération de la rue
monsieur qui n'existe plus en tant que
telle et à un moment où il est apparu
que partout dans les pays développés la
gestion des dossiers de coopération
devait être confié à une agence et ne
devait pas être fait par un ministère le
ministère devait donner les lignes
directrices établir la stratégie mais
c'est une agence qui devait monter les
actions c'est le cas avec l' agence
française de développement je dois aussi
insisté sur le fait qu' il s'agit
évidemment d'un établissement public à
caractère industriel et commercial mais
aussi d'une institution financière et
qu'elle a le fameux triple a que donnent
les agences de notation c'est à dire
qu'elle peut emprunter sur les marchés
dans les meilleures conditions et
derrière elle le fait puisque elle a un
rôle multiple elle est à la fois la
banque de nos territoires d'outre-mer
elle est la banque par lequel transitent
les dons de l'état aux pays qui ne
peuvent pas emprunter parce que ils sont
déjà en dehors des conditions d'emprunt
il pourrait pas rembourser et puis elle
est aussi une banque de développement
c'est-à-dire qu'elles prêtent avec des
taux qui peuvent être éventuellement
bonifié par le gouvernement français
elle fait tous ces métiers là avec des
techniciens qui apparaissent compétents
la preuve c'est que elle a gardé son
triple a mais ça n'empêche pas en effet
que des raies ce que souhaitable
justement dans la continuité de ce que
vous venez nous dire c'était l'un qui
revient d'investir des milliards d'euros
pour développer l'afrique notamment
beaucoup d'argent en jeu est
nécessairement d'elle crimes conjugaux
mis des parts d'ombré
je ne suis pas parfaitement d'accord le
faire ou la r d doit s'occuper de
développement de la clique et sur sa
seule vision et sa méthode je crois que
la r d doit aussi écouter les africains
écoutez la société civile africaine et
les désirs des populations et leur façon
d'aller vers cet accompagnement dans
cette population a besoin l'afd ne doit
pas seulement à faire le parallèle avec
les états étant donné qu'on n'a pas des
états fiables dans cette zone si on
avait d état correct d'une bonne
gouvernance et keith de tout fonctionne
normalement et que c'est une question de
lutte contre la pauvreté oui si
seulement la lutte contre la pauvreté ça
marchera mais c'est assez complète la
situation dans le sahel on apprend en
même temps cinq défis différents la
lutte contre le terrorisme la lutte pour
la sécurité et la stabilité
la lutte pour la liberté la démocratie
et la lutte contre la pauvreté il ya
tellement de lutte que ces populations
sont en train de mener tout est
maintenant ce qui s'est passé que les
politiques des états les politiques des
16 agences de développement les
politiques d'autres organisations se
sont tellement mélanger et tout devient
confus il est temps est urgent
d'éclaircir et donner à chacun sa
mission claire ce qui doit aider la
population à aider versé développement
et ceux qui font leurs politiques
publiques et leurs dépens de retard et
dans cette zone c'est très important de
pouvoir dissocier vous avez dit tout à
l'heure le début que cette crise où cet
article son homo mans où il ya une
tension politique sur entre la france le
gouvernement français et le gouvernement
actuel to marry sur des questions de la
vision au comment lutter contre le
terrorisme et c'est là maintenant en
train de sympathie sur la l'action de
l'afd voyez donc maintenant la question
de ce n'est plus tout cas de mon point
de vue la r d doit revoir sa passion de
faire de ne plus travailler avec
uniquement des états d'être très
exigeants et pointus dans les détails
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui l'afm ne peut
pas dire en donnant ces âmes en armant
ses militaires à l'effort mais qu'est-ce
que même si l'objectif aujourd'hui est
d'avoir des soldats qui respecte la
lutte pour les droits humains dans
l'émission de stabilité dans l'élite en
terrorisme la vie doit être très
exigeants tout cas c'est un militaire ne
tourne pas cette
population pour défendre des régimes
indéfendable c'est là et c'est un piège
ils doivent éviter ces pièces là et ne
peut pas dire
l'utilisation des ces armes ce n'est pas
nous en a donné les armes mais celui qui
les utilisent d'entre eux n'est pas
responsable non ce n'est pas possible si
encore une fois on est de cet état à
avoir des armes et digne le public aime
qu'elle espère des droits humains avant
de les amener dans des missions ailleurs
ou bien on ne forme pas un automne par
des armes car quand on sait que ces
critères sont potentiellement des
militaires indisciplinés et qui ne
respectent pas les droits jeunes a
classé la et la responsabilité de la
lpga tour blanche maison c'est vrai que
me met le doigt sur effectivement le
problème pour l' agence en gros la
responsabilité prend fin lorsque le
propriétaire d'aidé matérielle et
transférés aux bénéficiaires c'est vrai
que peut-être un peu facile est ce qu'on
n'aurait pas intérêt à changer
effectivement le contrôle l'organisation
le contrôle la transparence sur cette
agence moi je crois que monsieur a
raison et les problèmes qu'il a qui l'a
souligné découle de l'extension
considérable des champs d'action de
l'afd au cours des dernières années il
ya quelques années l'afd ne s'occupait
pas des questions de gouvernance ne
s'occupait pas des questions de sécurité
ne s'occupait pas des questions
militaires c'étaient les ministères qui
s'en occuper directement alors
effectivement je crois que ceci pourrait
être corrigée sans doute par l'action
des ambassades et des services de
coopération sur place les services de
coopération qui sont faits pour
dialoguer avec les gouvernements
bénéficiaires bien entendu il faut que
tout ça soit discuté il ya un dialogue
avec les sociétés civiles et c'est le
rôle de nos missions de coopération dans
les différents pays sous l'égide de
landaul en masse alors bien entendu et
puis peut-être qu'il faut aussi
améliorer le fonctionnement de l'agencé
elle-même comme vous le suggérez
actuellement elle est dirigée par un
conseil d'administration dans ce conseil
d'admistration il ya la tutelle c'est à
dire les trois ministères affaires
étrangères finances qui joue un rôle
capital et puis l'outre-mer et puis il y
a des députés des sénateurs au nombre de
4 5 personnalités qualifiées
et puis deux représentants du personnel
donc c'est assez équilibré et ça permet
au parlement d'être informés sur ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur de la fdt
probablement le parlement va s'inquiéter
de de ce qu'ont dit les lanceurs
dallaire que sont les journalistes qui
ont lancé cette cette affaire et vont
vouloir en savoir un peu plus c'est leur
droit le plus absolu puisque la loi de
finances sur la loi organique sur les
lois de finances les autorise à
interroger dans ces cas-là une agence
d'état une agence publique pour savoir
ce qui s'est exactement passé et
peut-être que dans l'avenir en effet il
faudra réformer certaines des procédures
l'agencé est avant tout un organisme
financier est effectivement comment un
organisme financier petit le dialogué
avec la société civile peut-il prendre
en compte les questions de droits de
l'homme peut-il prendre en compte les
manquements des militaires ou des
régimes autoritaires
c'est évidemment c'est plutôt le rôle
d'un organisme politique de faire ça et
c'est l'organisme politique les
ministères qui ont la tutelle qui
doivent donner instruction à l'afd vous
l'avez dit organismes financiers au delà
de la question des armes qu'on a évoqué
il ya évidemment la question prenons son
nom de la corruption sur sur le terrain
sous couvert d'ailleurs de secret
bancaire l'agent se refuse à donner le
nom de des collectivités des emprunteurs
des entreprises avec lesquelles elle
travaille on devrait selon vous monsieur
que l'on me lever ce secret bancaire
en effet les états dans lesquels la f10
intervient quand vous regardez dans le
classement des pays le plus corrompu du
monde un général et font partie des hp
letton dont quatre ans et quand on
arrive on intervient dans des états où
il n'ya pas de la transparence où la
corruption est endémique ou moi c'est
très bien et l'argent public pas
seulement à la zone délais de
développement même l'argent public du
trésor public détourné alors quand on
sait ces réalités lèvres ne doit pas de
sa responsabilité pour s'assurer que ce
qu'elle fait ne doit pas aboutir ou est
de tourner même si la ld donne de
l'argent et après cet argent est donné à
d'autres personnes ou des entreprises
ont des influences sont des réseaux
essaie de capter de la captation de ces
ressources au développement est
nécessaire de passer par ces autorités
qui sont des corrompus parfois ou qui
n'ont pas des tic dans la gestion de la
chose publique est bien la conséquence
c'est d'abord en ce moment en train de
parler de ce problème
donc il faut pas que le problème dans sa
dimension et mettre les choses en
perspective et que chacun paie sa
responsabilité s'enfermer dans sa durée
faire des secret bancaire ne résout pas
les problèmes on est l'un des
responsables étant donné puisque les
acteurs de ce clan penn s'est passé je
ne peux pas dire que dire que seulement
à cause de ses pour régler ces problèmes
il faut être transparent de bout en bout
qui soit au niveau de la r d ou au
niveau de ceux qui restent incertaines
et c'est là qu'une exigence doit être
réciproque ce qui donne et ce qu'ils le
soient le mot de la fin pour que la
blanche maison saine transparente cette
coopération notamment avec les pays du
sahel ça va être rendue encore plus
difficile avec ces tensions entre la
france et le mali aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui en effet une tension compte
tenu des déclarations qu'elle fait le
premier ministre du mali à l'onu samedi
dernier il a dit la france nous a laissé
tomber en plein vol ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait exact puisque la france dans
les six mois qui viennent va se retirer
de trois bases qu'elle a dans le
nord-mali mais elle reste ailleurs
deuxièmement le g5 sahel auxquelles la
france participe comme sixième membres
continuent également d'agir dans les
cinq pays qui constituent cette zone ya
pas que le mali le théâtre est beaucoup
plus vaste et puis enfin il ya la minus
ma la force de l'onu dont d'ailleurs le
premier ministre malien a demandé à
l'onu samedi dernier que ça son mandat
sera renforcée de façon à ce que cette
force de l'onu puissent agir
véritablement de façon offensive contre
les terroristes ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui alors tout ça est sur la
table effectivement plus les éventuels
participants tiers les etats unis qui
fournissent beaucoup de renseignements à
l'ensemble des troupes que père sur le
terrain les armes et des cinq pays qui
en fait ont vocation à prendre le relais
des militaires étrangers et à faire en
effet en sorte que les les
les ministres qui sont ils et qui
veulent troubler l'ordre public puisse
être chassés de leur pays et puis
peut-être d'autres pays on entend dire
un peu partout que en effet
un organisme privé russe est en
négociations avec le gouvernement du
mali c'est bien possible d'ailleurs le
ministre de la défense et le premier
ministre du mali ont été formés à moscou
il ya eu déjà des coopérations donc à ce
moment là il faudra voir en effet si ça
se produit si ça se confirme comment ces
interventions se coordonnant avec les
autres parce que ça peut être dangereux
d'intervenir en ordre dispersé sans
aucune concertation
sociétés privées effectivement sa grille
la vente disais que ça n'avait rien à
voir avec le gouvernement russe en tout
cas c'était le message qu'il a fait
passer il ya deux jours merci claude
blanchemaison merci également à vous
avez lé crime koundougou me
lutter contre la désinformation sur le
web et les théories complotistes
l'elysée va lancer prochainement la
commission brauner pour contrer ce fléau
un groupe d'une quinzaine d'experts dont
des sociologues des professeurs en
géopolitique journalistes et acteurs de
terrain le groupe doit rendre un rapport
d'ici fin décembre mais la composition
et la crédibilité de ce rapport
interroge ali et marc aussi
mesurer les dangers du numérique sur la
cohésion nationale et nos institutions
afin de mieux y faire face c'est
l'objectif de cette commission bronner
une commission de lutte contre l'effet
news et le complotisme lancé par
emmanuel macron ce mercredi il faut dire
qu'on a senti à plusieurs reprises
l'exaspération du chef de l'état face à
ce phénomène le problème clé pour moi
c'est l'écrasement des hiérarchies
induits par la société du commentaire
permanent le sentiment que tout se vaut
que toutes les paroles sont égales celle
de quelqu'un qui n'est pas spécialiste
mais un avis sur le virus vaut la voie
d'un scientifique ou dans un style moins
soutenu jojo avec un gilet jaune a le
même statut qu'un ministre ou un député
les gilet jaune apprécieront d'autant
que l'effet news le complotisme voire la
désinformation ne sont pas l'apanage des
gilets jaunes ou des mouvements anti
vaccins ou anti passe sanitaire trois
millions de vaccins ont été créés au
moment où je vous parle et c'est la même
occasion c'est le premier score européen
mais est non et l'information était
vérifiable assez facilement sur le site
covit tracker au suivant vidocq et
beaucoup de détournements de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire on sait
bien que enfin si on a si on regarde les
choses en face que parfois il ya des
achats d'écrans plats plus important au
mois de septembre car d'autres moments
donc et non encore une fois et ce mythe
vieux de près de 15 ans plus personne ne
dit écran plat aujourd'hui ce mythe
était déjà battue en brèche par
l'exécutif lui même en 2018 on essaye
encore ici à la pitié salpêtrière on a
attaqué un hôpital on a agressé son
personnel soignant et on a blessé un
policier mobilisé pour le protéger
indéfectible soutien à nos forces de
l'ordre elles sont la fierté de la
république et c'est encore raté aucune
agression de soignants ce 1er mai 2010 9
mai des manifestants qui tentent
d'échapper aux gaz lacrymogènes tirés
par les forces de l'ordre d'ailleurs ce
tweet de christophe castaner deux
sénateurs communistes ont tenté de le
faire retiré en vertu de la loi anti
flics news une loi concoctée par le
gouvernement actuel un outil déjà
supposé lutter contre la désinformation
et qui n'a pas fonctionné comme prévu
puisque le ministre a été blanchi par le
tribunal il n'aurait je cite qu'exagéré
chacun se fera son opinion on pourra
aussi revenir sur la théorie farfelue de
la création des gilet jaune parant
conseiller de donald trump la fable des
chômeurs soient indemnisés ou les
influences selon emmanuel macron de la
fachosphère de la gauchosphère et de la
rue se faire c'est vrai que ça commence
à bien faire autre complot l'origine de
l'épidémie qui aurait fuité d'un
laboratoire p4 haouran à ce sujet rudy
reichstadt directeur de conspiracy watch
et membre de la commission justement
avait une explication c'est la
conjugaison d'une très grande méfiance
et d'un profond analphabétisme une
importante partie de la population n'a
aucune conscience de son incompétence
avant on respecter davantage la parole
des experts oui sauf que cette thèse
n'est plus présentée comme si
invraisemblable bien au contraire comme
spira si ocz qui a d'ailleurs publié il
ya près de quatre ans les résultats d'un
sondage sur le complotisme
chez les français une enquête à la
méthodologie contestées alors il n'est
pas question de jeter l'opprobre sur
cette commission ni sur ses intentions
ou ses membres toute tentative de rendre
plus un le paysage médiatique et les
réseaux sociaux est louable mais on
espère en revanche qu'elle restera aussi
indépendante que ce qu'annonce gérald
bronner les mécaniques du complotisme
sont complexes et la défiance envers le
gouvernement en fait partie surtout
lorsque ce gouvernement ne fait pas
preuve de l'irréprochabilité qu'on
attend de lui
le patron de l'om est-ce s'excuse et
promet de punir les coupables à
l'institution est gravement mise en
cause par une commission d' enquête
indépendante à l'accusé une vingtaine
d'employés de l'organisation de
violences sexuelles commises en
république démocratique du congo entre
2018 et 2020 pour ms alors chargé de
lutter contre l'épidémie d'ebola le
récit de marion caudal
le directeur de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé dans une situation
inconfortable
une commission d' enquête indépendante à
dévoiler ses conclusions sur les
violences sexuelles commises par des
employés de l'organisation cette
dernière est accusée de défaillances
structurelles et de négligences
individuelles tedros adhanom
gebreyesus en campagne pour sa
réélection a présenté ses excuses hull
city c'est
tous des victimes
c'est la première chose que je veux dire
est aux victimes et aux survivants de
l'exploitation et des abus sexuels
décrits dans le rapport de la commission
je suis désolé
je suis désolé de ce qui vous a été fait
par des personnes qui étaient employés
par l'om est ce pour vous servir et les
protéger je suis désolé pour la
souffrance permanente que ces événements
doivent causer
à mme soledad durable
je suis désolé que vous ayez du lait
revivre en parlant de vos expériences à
la commission je vous remercie tous
courage donc vous avez fait preuve en le
faisant ce qui vous est arrivé ne
devrait jamais arriver à perth 1 c'est
inexcusable apple
était inexcusable
ma priorité absolue est de veiller à ce
que les auteurs de ces actes ne soit pas
excusé mais qu'ils aient à rendre des
comptes
des comptes qui n'ont jamais eu à rendre
avant cette enquête puisque parmi les 21
employés de l' oms accusée quatre
d'entre eux étaient toujours en fonction
quand d'autres étaient en contrat court
et la plupart avaient quitté
l'organisation après la fin de
l'épidémie ebola à l'époque les alertes
remontées depuis la rdc n'avait pas fait
réagir les responsables de l' oms
certains sont donc suspendus en
attendant les résultats de l'enquêté
mais le directeur de l'organisation et
lui le sentais comme la directrice du
bureau africain
oui in deutschland
en mode l oms nous sommes en effet
humilié horrifié est déchirée par les
conclusions de cette enquête j'aimerais
également remercier toutes les femmes et
les jeunes filles qui se sont manifestés
et ont témoigné dans le cadre de l'
enquête et qui nous ont ainsi fourni la
base sur laquelle nous avons pu prendre
des mesures à l'om est ce ce qui était
nécessaire que
des femmes qui se sont fait entendre
après l' enquête du réseau de newman
terrienne et de la route hers fondation
ente route 2018 et juin 2020 alors que
l'om s était tenue d'endiguer l'épidémie
d'ebola ces travailleurs en profiter de
leur position en abusant sexuellement
deux femmes congolaises
au total 75 victimes ont été identifiées
la plus jeune d'entre elles étant âgé de
13 ans seulement l'équipe d'examen a pu
établir que
les victimes présumées se voyaient
promettre des emplois à l'échelle des
relations ou été exploités sexuellement
pour avoir et au conserver un emploi au
sein de la réponse un énième scandale
d'abus sexuels avant le msc l'onu qui
était visé en centrafrique 450 casques
bleus gabonais sont également accusés de
violences sexuelles
les choses avancent enfin en tunisie il
ya une dizaine de jours le président qui
essayent d'annoncer la future nomination
d'un chef de gouvernement son nom a été
annoncé ce matin neige abou dehn
première femme nommée à ce poste en
tunisie en fait le point sur place avec
d'autres correspondants bassam chili
après plus de deux mois d'attenté de
silence qui accède enfin à dévoiler le
nom du nouveau chef du gouvernement il
s'agit d'une femme la première dans
l'histoire politique de la tunisie à
occuper un tel poste la nouvelle chef du
gouvernement on devra entre autres
poursuivre les travaux engagés par le
président de la république notamment en
matière de lutte contre la corruption je
vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet qu al
sayed président de la république
tunisienne nous travaillerons ensemble à
l'avenir avec une détermination
inébranlable pour éliminer la corruption
et le chaos dans de nombreuses
institutions de l'état
le travail doit être fait rapidement et
l'équipe que vous dirigerez doit être
homogène et doit travailler avant tout
sur la lutte contre la corruption nadja
bouden a donc été chargé par le chef de
l'état de former un gouvernement dans
les plus brefs délais a annoncé dans un
communiqué la présidence de la
république il s'agira donc du 10e
gouvernement depuis la révolution
tunisienne de 2011 né en 1958 la
nouvelle chef du gouvernement ingénieur
de formation docteur en géologie est
diplômé de l'école nationale supérieure
des mines de paris a occupé plusieurs
postes dans les gouvernements précédents
originaire de kairouan dans le centre du
pays elle a été directrice générale
chargée de la qualité au ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur puis chargé de
mission auprès du cabinet du ministère
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche scientifique en 2015 après des
mois de crise politique et de gels de
l'assemblée nationale cet intellectuel
de 63 ans a la lourde tâche de
constituer dans les jours à venir le
nouveau gouvernement attendu par les
tunisiens seule alternative à une sortie
de crise qui paralyse le pays depuis le
25 juillet dernier
et direction à présent les états unis
joe biden vite une semaine cruciale au
congrès des démocrates doivent
impérativement s'accorder dans les
prochaines heures avec les républicains
s'il veulent prouver le programme du
président américain au coeur de
l'impasse t gigantesques investissements
dans les infrastructures et réformes
sociales historiques pour en parler on
retrouve notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet bonsoir
l'objectif est donc désormais d'empêcher
le showdown éviter en clair la paralysie
soudaine du gouvernement fédéral
oui cette semaine et présenté dans les
médias américains comme certainement la
semaine la plus importante du mandat de
joe biden puisque avant demain soir le
budget du gouvernement doit être voté
par le congrès sinon il ya un risque
qu'il y est un chef donne c'est à dire
une paralysie d'une partie des services
administratifs américain alors si les
républicains ont rejeté ce vote du
budget c'est parce qu'il a été couplée à
une demande pour réhausser le plafond de
la dette américaine c'est une manoeuvre
assez récurrente à ces communes puisque
le plafond de cette dette a déjà été
relevé 80 fois depuis les années 60 mais
cette fois donc les républicains s'y
opposent ils ne veulent pas distille
donné carte blanche à joe biden pour
mener sa politique et écouter les
c'était donc hier
il n'y a aucune chance aucune chance que
la conférence républicaine fasse tout
son possible pour aider des démocrates à
préserver leur temps et leur énergie
afin qu'ils puissent recommencer à faire
adopter le socialisme partisans aussi
vite que possible
les démocrates vont donc devoir revoir
leur feuille de route pour à minima au
moins faire voter à ce budget d'ici
demain soir et pour éviter des
conséquences assez importantes sur
l'économie américaine mais les
démocrates sont aussi concentrés sur un
autre dossier qui est très important
c'est donc ces deux plans promis par joe
biden lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle
des plans d'investissement qui comporte
deux volets d'abord 1000 milliards de
dollars d'investissement pour les
infrastructures sur l'ensemble du
territoire américain et puis un autre
volet cette fois 3500 milliards de
dollars qui concerne donc des réformes
sociales la couverture santé l'éducation
encore des lois pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique alors au sein
du parti démocrate il y a deux
parlementaires qu'on qualifiera plutôt
de centristes qui bloque pour le moment
l'adoption de ces plans ils veulent eux
se concentrer d'abord sur le plan qui
concerne les infrastructures parce
qu'ils disent que c'est plus consensuel
ils veulent reporter à plus tard le vote
sur les réformes sociales sauf que eh
bien cela crée un blocage au sein du
parti parce que à l'opposé de
l'échiquier politique en tout cas au
sein du parti démocrate à la gauche on
estime qu'il faut voter les deux plans
simultanément ou alors on ne votera pas
écouter ce que disait notamment bernie
sanders
aucun projet de loi sur l'infrastructure
ne devrait être adopté sans un projet de
loi de réconciliation de 3 milliards 500
millions de dollars c'est l'accord qui a
été conclu et c'est l'accord qui doit
être respecté l'infrastructure physique
est importante mais les besoins des
familles de travailleurs et la lutte
contre le changement climatique sont
plus importants les progressistes à la
chambre et au sénat sont prêts à mettre
en oeuvre l'ensemble du programme du
président biden intitulé bild bac bête
cela signifie qu'il faut investir non
seulement dans les routes et les ponts
mais aussi dans les personnes et les
communautés
il ya donc des tractations politiques
qui se joue en ce moment en coulisses
avec énormément de réunions au sein du
parti et démocrates il faut dire que
l'enjeu est assez énorme pour joe biden
qui joue une partie de son mandat avec
la présentation de ces deux plans qui
étaient en réalité des promesses qu'il a
faites lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle il sait aussi que l'année
prochaine il y aura les élections de mi
mandat qu'il pourrait potentiellement
perdre la majorité au congrès et que
c'est donc maintenant qu'il doit agir et
la preuve de l'importance accordée à ce
dossier par le locataire de la maison
blanche c'est qu'il a annulé un
déplacement initialement prévue ce
mercredi à chicago pour parler de la
vaccination et ce afin de rester à la
maison blanche et de recevoir les
différents acteurs de ce processus
législatif merci thomas bonnin en direct
donc 2 washington et on va plus loin
avec mendy yellow ce président des
républicains envers six france bonsoir
monsieur merci d'être avec nous
démocrates et républicains vont t'ils
s'accorder selon vous
je crois pas dans un premier temps jeu
steam qui est ce qu'ils vont faire et je
ne sais pas si ça a été bien indiqués il
ya aussi les questions de faire voter un
plan provisoire et temporaire pour le
prochain deux mois parce que pour éviter
le choc
oh l'arrêt des du gouvernement fédéral
ils peuvent envisager un budget a
pendant deux mois jusqu'au 2 décembre
cependant il ya un blocage important et
aux scènes de la parti républicain
concernant le plafond d'endettement qui
aujourd'hui aucun des républicains est
d'accord pour accorder ce sera un chèque
en blanc donné administration by demi
qu'on estime et responsables continuent
ddd dépenses colossales qui ont encore
par leur administration et que on estime
qu'ils aient leur administration étant
irresponsable par rapport à l'amérique
et les conséquences que ça aura sur
l'économie américaine il faut savoir qui
et on n'a pas parlé dans votre reportage
qui est ça comporte une partie aussi à
des mesures fiscales les plus importants
depuis plusieurs décennies et qui les
familles les plus modestes vont être
imposées dans le cadre de ce plan des 5
milliards dé dollars et ils vont le
faire payer halle aux américains selon
des mesures fiscales seront des
impositions records qu'il n'a jamais vue
aux états unis et aujourd'hui quand vous
entendez manar pelosi et des autres
démocrates parler de ce projet ait dit
ça va coûter 0 parce que qu'ils vont
aller chez les américains ont leur faire
payer ces maisons là et aujourd'hui les
républicains appellent les démocraties
mais la responsabilité des dénommés
mesure et on leur demander s'ils
souhaitent procéder
assez déplafonnement des landes
vêtements qu'elle assume tout seul et
comme vous voyez vous coupez d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que vous êtes là pour
compléter ce reportage inquiète un
reportage factuel vous êtes là pour
apporter votre opinion de d'ailleurs
ça veut dire quoi concrètement selon
vous il n'ya pas de ce n'est pas un
budget sincère comme on dirait en france
il n'est pas assez franc il n'assume pas
c'est ça que vous reprochez à la jarrie
jeu aujourd'hui pour vous donner un
petit exemple la projets verts des
démocrates qu'est ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis on a fait subir aux familles
les plus modestes d d d augmentation des
prix des gaz et d'énergie qu'on n'a
jamais vus depuis deux décennies avec
les réformes qu'ils proposent ces prix
vont augmenter
aujourd'hui aussi toute la politique ils
ont arrêté d'exploitation des gaz aux
etats-unis et on voit les prix des gaz
augmente et du pétrole de tout ce qui
est l'énergie augmente aux états unis et
il est choisi à adopter je vous explique
non parce que les maisons qu'ils ont mis
en place qui est en partie une volée à
et environnemental très important par
rapport à ce qu'ils sont en train de
défaire et et ça à cette partie là aussi
ça reproduit le même projet vert qui a
été mis en place en allemagne et qui
était un échec ces dernières cinq à huit
ans et ils vont répéter la même chose et
on va faire face à une situation très
problématique aux états unis qu'on va
dépendre des voitures électriques qui
toutes les sources d'énergie qu'on
n'achète que ce soit des gaz de pétrole
et aussi tout ce qui est des tiers mais
tu des sources pour les voitures
électriques d'où ça vient de l'étranger
et surtout de la chine on va créer une
dépendance à sur la chine qui va être
renforcée par cette politique qui sera
mis en place et aujourd'hui on doit dire
un moment donné stop et a aujourd'hui
et il ya cet encouragement de la part
des démocrates de vouloir les sons
réfléchir et je considère que nous de
notre côté qui les défendent volée
qu'ils ont mis en place sont excessives
et on a essayé de négocier au sein des
décombres républicain un budget beaucoup
plus modeste beaucoup plus tempérée par
rapport aux différents objectifs qui ont
été prévues pour aider l'économie on ne
se rend pas compte que les milliers des
milliards qui ont été dépensés et qui
aujourd'hui on voit bien entendu les
effets des situations on voit une
inflation massive aux etats-unis du
jamais vu depuis à deux décennies donc
c'est ce qui va se passer aux états unis
est évidemment aussi vivement critiqué
pour certains de ses choix en politique
étrangère notamment le retrait précipité
d'afghanistan en tout cas la manière de
retirer ses troupes il est justement en
train de payer ses choix en matière de
politique étrangère également ça n'a
rien à voir selon
moi je considère ip les prix il paie un
prix important parce que c'est sa
politique domestique et ce public
international sont tous les deux liés
par exemple aujourd'hui il essaie de
faire passer une politique verte mais on
nous accordons on on quitte
l'afghanistan ce qui est connu comme
l'arabie saoudite du lithium il a passé
toutes les ressources du huitième à la
chine il a ouvert cette mine cette
réserve mondiale du 8e qu'il va nous
serons plus dépendants de la chine et
qui aujourd'hui ils autre côté qui veut
dire aux américains on va vers une
économie verte dépendant des voitures
électriques et qui dispose d des
monopoles de toutes les matières
premières aujourd'hui c'est la chine qui
vient de donner les deuxièmes réserves
du monde oh oh oh régime à chinois et il
doit faire face à cette situation
comment ça s'explique comment on peut
expliquer aux américains qu'on va créer
de plus en plus de dépendance sur des
pays étrangers surtout non sur un pays
qu'on concède hostiles aux intérêts mais
comme la chine est aujourd'hui les
américains font de moins un confiance à
messieurs byden ses choix son
indifférence vis-à-vis des américains il
doit aussi s'expliquer sur sa politique
fiscale qui va mettre en place parce
qu'aujourd'hui on va se rendre compte
que les imac avec l'inflation est tout
coûte plus cher des niveaux que ce soit
l'alimentation
c'était le début de votre intervention
cette mesure fiscale comment subir selon
rappelle que vous êtes président des
républicains envers six france merci à
vous et avocats en commun américain
merci bien et on vient de l'évoquer
cette décision de retirer les troupes
américaines d'afghanistan très critiqué
les chef du pentagone reconnaissent
publiquement des erreurs de jugement
évoque même un échec stratégique
et admettent avoir été pris par surprise
par l'effondrement immédiat de l'armée
afghane des aveux à peine voilée hier
devant le sénat américain un retour sur
cette audition avec hélène masquelier
une remise en cause de la crédibilité
des états unis voilà ce qui ressort des
échanges de ce mardi le chef
d'état-major de l'armée face à un sénat
remonter à essuyer les critiques des
représentants
précipitation manque d'anticipation
si le chef du pentagone a tenté de
défendre les décisions de son président
il a aussi concédé des manquements dans
l'opération menée en afghanistan
utiliseriez-vous l'expression succès
extraordinaire pour désigner ce qui
s'est passé en août en afghanistan
il s'agit de l'évacuation de non
combattants et je pense que l'un des
autres sénateurs l'a très bien dit
c'était un succès logistique mais un
échec stratégique
également relevé par les sénateurs des
désaccords entre les gradés du pentagone
et le président le chef du commandement
central américain a admis avoir
conseillé joe biden de maintenir un
petit contingent de soldats pour éviter
l'effondrement de kaboul affirmation qu
avait rejeté le président américain j'ai
recommandé que nous maintenions 2500
soldats en afghanistan
je pense également que le retrait de ces
forces conduirait inévitablement à
l'effondrement des forces militaires
afghanes et à terme du gouvernement
afghan
la porte parole de la maison blanche a
rapidement réagi dans l'après midi
rappelant le haut gradé à l'ordre
personne n'a dit que dans cinq ans nous
pourrions avoir de 1500 soldats et que
ce serait intenable en fin de compte
c'est au commandant chef de décider et
il a décidé qu'il était temps de mettre
fin à 20 ans de guerre autre tacle
contre joe biden le secrétaire américain
de la défense a reconnu un manque de
discernement face à la situation à
kaboul précédent le retrait des troupes
le fait que l'armée afghane et les ali
que nous avions formé tout simplement
battu en retraite à de nombreuses
occasions sans tirer un seul coup de feu
nous a tous pris par surprise et serait
malhonnête de prétendre le contraire
nous devons admettre certaines vérités
inconfortables que nous n'avons pas
pleinement compris la profondeur de la
corruption et le manque de leadership
dans les rangs supérieurs de l'armée
afghane
après cette longue journée de
confrontation au sénat les trois hommes
vont de nouveau être entendue ce
mercredi
cette fois la chambre des représentants
les chefs du pentagone n'ont pas fini de
se justifier
c'est avec nous dans quelques instants
notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous aller à la rencontre des
habitants de tignes et dans le maine et
loire qui ont obtenu gain de cause dans
leur lutte contre les éoliennes se
trouveront devant chez eux alors que
certains politiques comme les verts
appellent à la multiplication des
recours aux éoliennes
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on dit dans
les grandes entreprises multinationales
de saint gobain russie ukraine on a
beaucoup dit que bon
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul bert moi je suis convaincu à
titre personnel que il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les observe t il il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays en développement sur partout
partout vous avez construit des usines
décarbonés vont des usines roues on
n'aimait rien du tout comme carbone dans
l' usine que ce soit nos émissions
directes ou alors des émissions liées à
la production d'électricité nous en
avons aujourd'hui dans le monde donc là
la conscience écologique aussi existe en
russie
[Musique]
le résultat un dieu peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
la communication des modèles mâcon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
kicked off est-ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique ils
pensent eux ça va ramener les jeunes à
la politique dont il se désintéresserait
en lieu et place de politiser les jeunes
ça dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus cooney sq justement c'est
une nouvelle forme de communication
assez verticale utiliser des
influenceurs pour ça comme politique
personnelle est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est vraiment nouveau d'utiliser des
célébrités pour faire de la propagande
politique on s'en fiche nous on veut
quelqu'un qui dirige la france comme
c'est son travail en notre nom pour nous
est dans notre intérêt à tous
[Musique]
et
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi qui ait des candidats
n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
politique il est clair que tout le monde
attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l oblique
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommet de cette demi heure notre
rubrique on pense les français alors que
les fortes hausses des tarifs du gaz et
d'électricité inquiètent la question de
la transition énergétique monte en
puissance à sept mois de la
présidentielle
certains comme les verts appellent à la
multiplication du recours aux éoliennes
mais sur le terrain qu'on pense la
population concernée nous sommes allés à
la rencontre des habitants de tignes et
dans le maine et loire qui ont obtenu
gain de cause dans leur lutte contre les
éoliennes se trouvant devant chez eux
[Musique]
disaient cette man avant le scrutin
présidentiel parmi les grands enjeux de
cette campagne déjà bien amorcée par
certains l'écologie avec en particulier
le sujet très controversé du nucléaire
qui divise la classe politique série el
bulli
durant son mandat emmanuel macron l'a
répété à maintes reprise
l'avenir de la france passe par le
nucléaire
pourtant la position du gouvernement
actuel reste flou en décembre dernier
lors de la convention climat la question
du nucléaire est laissée de côté
à droite les voix semblent unanimes
redonner une place centrale au nucléaire
en france c'est le cas de xavier
bertrand candidats les républicains à la
présidentielle mais aussi de la
candidate élèves valérie pécresse
une france zéro carbone d'ici à 2050
l'objectif est clair pour la présidente
de la région ile de france qui souhaite
relancer l'industrie nucléaire avec la
construction de six réacteurs à eau
pressurisée européen le rassemblement
national mené par marine le pen a choisi
de défendre le nucléaire et d'en faire
une priorité nationale absolue
du côté de la gauche yannick jadot
candidat écologiste a pour objectif de
sortir la france du nucléaire d'ici à
vingt ans la france insoumise et le
parti génération ont décidé de suivre
cette position le ps lui reste prudent
si le parti annonce souhaité une énergie
d'origine 100% renouvelable d'ici à 2050
il ne se positionne pas totalement sur
la poursuite ou non de l'exploitation
des réacteurs nucléaires existants
en avril 2020 un décret gouvernemental a
permis l'adoption d'un programme qui
s'étale jusqu'en 2028 avec pour objectif
le développement des énergies
renouvelables sur tout le territoire en
particulier l'énergie éolienne
alors la france doit-elle faire le choix
de développer ces énergies renouvelables
et notamment son parc éolien les pour et
les contres y vont de leurs arguments
mais qu'en pensent les français aux
principaux intéressés en particulier
ceux qui subissent l'implantation
d'éoliennes à proximité de leurs
habitations
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de
bernadette car ce dans le maine-et-loire
parc s'est construit tout près de chez
elle après une longue procédure
judiciaire elle a obtenu gain de cause
un reportage signé nadia japet razaka
nous sommes à tignes et dans le maine et
loire dans l'ouest de la france pour y
retrouver berne est d'être car ce
bonjour merci de nous accueillir chez
vous alors c'est une véritable victoire
pour vous racontez nous oui alors c'est
une victoire financièrement c'est pas
quelque chose qui va changer ma vie et
ça n'est pas l'objectif de cette de
cette procédure l'objectif c'était de
faire reconnaître
par l'administration par le tribunal
administratif et par le service des
impôts que oui nous subissons des
nuisances que même si le permis de
construire a été accordé il ne signifie
pas qu'il n'y aura pas de nuisances pour
les riverains et que ceux ci doivent
être indemnisées au même titre que les
communes alors pour faire court une
éolienne c'est un appareil qui
transforme l'énergie du vent en
électricité
donc ça fait partie de ce qu'on appelle
les énergies renouvelables
et vous vous appelez les français et
vaut à commencer par vos voisins a à
dire non à ces éoliennes qu'est ce que
vous leur reprochez précisément vous
parlez de nuisance est ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer oui globalement
ceux qui sont en faveur de l'éolien sont
ceux qui n'en subissent pas les
nuisances et ce qui financièrement sont
intéressés à la faire
maintenant pourquoi nous on s'y opposent
parce que effectivement nous nous savons
qu'il ya des nuisances et nous les
soumettons à personne
notre combat c'est de bien dire
attention vous nous dites que vous
veniez sauver la planète vous venez
faire de l'écologie mais en fait vous
dévasté l'environnement bernadette vous
me parliez des nuisances sonores et
visuelles qui vous gâcher un petit peu
la vie au quotidien qu'est ce que ça
fait concrètement de vivre à 850 mètres
d'un parc éolien quand on habite à la
campagne près d'un parc éolien très
simplement envie moins bien on vit moins
bien parce qu'on a des nuisances que
nous n'avions pas nous avons le bruit et
nous avons leur présence elle mesure 120
m de haut elle dévore notre horizon
elles dévastent notre paysage et c'est
vrai que le bruit est quelque chose
d'incongru ici ce bruit industriel
le bruit d'une éolienne peut démarrer
n'importe quand le jour la nuit les
jours fériés et vous avez un bruit comme
celui d'une machine à laver dans le
jardin et vous me dites ces éoliennes
elles ne servent à rien elles ne
produisent pas suffisamment d'énergie
mais pourquoi vous dites ça parce qu'il
ya pas de suffisamment de vent vous
dites que leur remplacement il est il
est pas réfléchi des études n'ont pas
été menées en amont le promoteur n'a pas
étudié le terrain et les conditions
météo avant de s'installer le promoteur
il étudie surtout la quantité des
subventions qui va recevoir à vous ne
dites que c'est purement c'est purement
un produit financier oui totalement avec
ce parc là le chiffre d'affaires annoncé
par le promoteur ses 105 mille euros par
mois garanti pendant 20 ans aucune autre
entreprise ne bénéficie d'une telle
sécurité le premier ministre jean castex
a récemment annoncé un plan
de 25 milliards d'euros pour les
énergies renouvelables
ce que je regrette c'est que l'écologie
était prise en main par les politiques
alors que l'écologie c'est normalement
réservé aux scientifiques
comment est ce qu'on fait alors bourg et
bien créé notre énergie notre
électricité on continue dans le
nucléaire
malgré tout ce qu'on sait du nucléaire
des dents gérer on prend le risque de
faire face à une grave catastrophe comme
ça a été le cas par exemple
tchernobyl fukushima
oui c'est effectivement l'argument jouer
sur la peur pour nous imposer des
éoliennes
le problème c'est que tous les
scientifiques le disent pour lutter
contre les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre l'éolien ne sert à rien avec ses
milliards que jean castex veut donner
aux promoteurs est-ce qu'on aurait pas d
usage beaucoup plus intelligent je pense
que offrir d isolation de toiture les
offrir
ça nous coûterait beaucoup moins cher et
sera un impact parce que là nous aurions
des économies d'énergie renouvelable
l'éolien n'a jamais fait preuve de son
efficacité on ne leur demande même pas
d'être efficace
regardez les garder les servent à quoi
elles ont un taux de facteur de charge
d'après les promoteurs d'environ 27%
stella 27 % du temps elle tourne à plein
régime le reste du temps elle tourne 5
minutes 10 minutes elle arrête elles
repartent mais combien de machines
fonctionnent aussi mal que l'éolien mois
j'achèterai même pas un frigo qui
fonctionne aussi mal que l'éolien qu'est
ce que vous attendez vous de la
prochaine élection présidentielle et des
candidats qui vont s'affronter
pour cette échéance électorale alors ce
que nous attendons des élections c'est
sûr que nous allons demander à chacun
des candidats de se positionner de se
positionner sur ses liens financiers
avec le business éolien de se
positionner sur
leur envie ou non de protéger le monde
rural et de se positionner sur les choix
écologiques efficaces à faire parce que
je rappelle que dans le code de
l'énergie la première chose à faire
c'est de limiter les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et de garder un prix de
l'énergie tolérable pour tout le monde
en nous savons qu'en ce moment le prix
d'électricité atteint des plafonds
c'est vraiment l'appauvrissement notre
pays et de tous alors question faut-il
plus d'éoliennes pour sortir du tout
nucléaire est ce la bonne stratégie pour
avoir une électricité propre et à prix
convenable c'est l'objet de notre face à
face
[Musique]
avec nous pourrons parler sur ce plateau
arthur paris ce membre de l'association
des amis des ligues zemmour bonsoir
arthur parisse merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés en face en direct jean marc
governatori
coprésidents écologie au centre bonsoir
monsieur merci d'être avec nous vous
étiez candidat à la primaire des verts
je précise merci d'être en direct avec
mohamoud un mot donc pour commencer sur
ce témoignage qu'on vient d'entendre
cette femme bernadette car ça des mots
très durs ceux qui sont en faveur de
l'éolien sont ceux qui ne subissent pas
les nuisances et qui sont intéressés à
la faire en tant qu'aide enjeux
écologiques jean marc governatori
quelle est votre réaction à ce genre de
discours a évidemment en berne avec car
ce n'est pas forcément un témoignage
isolé il faut il faut bien vivre
à tout à fait tout à fait mais en
prendre et dans le monde on peut pas
dire les écologistes il y à différentes
sensibilités au sein des écologistes moi
je représente en france techologie
centriste et on n'est pas obsédé par les
éoliennes donc le fait est que l'ue ne
pas en vouloir plus quand même
en vouloir plus en accord avec les
habitants on peut pas travailler à nos
positions avec les habitent en france
aujourd'hui il y à 8000 éoliennes et les
huit éoliennes n'ont pas été imposée à
tous les habitants il ya des attentes
sont d'accord parce qu'ils sont
particulièrement écologistes ou
particulièrement sensibles à la
problématique énergétique mais moi me
suis pas un fana des éoliennes les deux
premières sources d'énergie sont d'abord
l'éducation à l'environnement parce
qu'on peut moins gaspiller et avoir
besoin d'au moins d'énergie et par
ailleurs l'isolation les deux premières
sources d'énergie sont bien celles là
isolation éducation à l'environnement
l'éolien doit faire d'un mix énergétique
mais pour ce qui nous concerne nous
écologistes centristes nous est
favorable autre champ d'éoliennes et
nous sommes défavorables aux maires par
contre nous aimons ce qui est petit
parce que le vrai écologistes préfèrent
ces petits as tes grands donc nous
croyons au mini éoliennes sur des toits
d'immeubles par exemple prenez un
immeuble fait une bonne isolation et sur
le toit vous pouvez vous mettez du
solaires et une éolienne
vous allez vous approchez de l'autonomie
énergétique de l'immeuble en question
dans des écoles yeux une éolienne c'est
qu'il ya dix éoliennes partout nous n'y
sommes pas favorables on en parlera
évidemment jean marc governatori parce
que on va aussi peut-être en parler
voilà de l'efficacité c'est vrai que si
vous mettez pas beaucoup d'éoliennes
peut-être que ça va pas forcément
produire le résultat escompté mais enfin
on va on va revenir évidemment là dessus
alors cette question des éoliennes on
l'aura compris est elle provoque
vraiment une une fracture ans déjà on le
voit dans la classe politique je vous
propose d'écouter l'avis de celui qui
fait voilà beaucoup aux des morts en ce
moment votre candidat en tout cas vous
l'espérez puisqu'on rappelle toujours
qui ne s'est pas encore déclaré
officiellement eric zemmour voici ce qui
ce qu'ils en pensent tout le mal qu'il
pense de ces éoliennes
les éoliennes c'est une catastrophe on
en a pas besoin en france des éoliennes
ces boues pour les pays qui n'ont pas de
nucléaire
rappelle qu'eric zemmour voilà même nom
officiellement candidat pour l'instant
est à 13 % dans les sondages donc c'est
une candidature qui devient évidemment
crédible et intéressante donc on a envie
d'avoir votre avis ce soir c'est un
petit peu radicale on en n'a pas du tout
besoin en france des éoliennes alors à
petit en france on a peu voire pas
besoin pour une raison simple c'est
qu'on est extrêmement performant sur
nucléaire le nucléaire aujourd'hui c'est
une énergie qui est décarbonée qui est
puissante et dont on a la maîtrise
depuis quarante à cinquante ans donc sur
la question de l'éolien effectivement
vous avez raison de souligner le sujet
il va falloir comparer la performance
énergétique et on réalise aujourd'hui on
le savait déjà que sur la performance
énergétique de l'éolien face au
nucléaire on ne peut même pas les
comparer donc il s'agit aujourd'hui de
dire qu'il faut arrêter cette politique
de l'éolien qui est une pollution
visuelle déjà qui est une pollution
aussi
des terres ces 400 mètres cubes de béton
dans le sol c'est mille tonnes de béton
armé dans le sol ce sont des pales ont
fait importer de chine avec des produits
des minerais rares qu'on est incapable
de recycler qu'on enfouit dans les sols
qu'on exporte voir dans les pays
d'afrique pour les faits rend fou rire
là bas donc cette réalité de l'éolien il
faut la voir dans son intégrité et
aujourd'hui le nucléaire est une réponse
parfaite adéquate aux enjeux
énergétiques qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui et dans les années à venir
vous voulez retirer alors si eric
zemmour
élus bon alors qu'il n'est pas candidat
on le rappelle un ton jour tout de même
mais
soit les retirer tout simplement n'ont
alors pas nécessairement aujourd'hui
elles sont là déjà à ce qu'on peut faire
c'est avant d'y retirer s'est arrêté
d'en planter de nouvelles aujourd'hui on
a un exemple on a plutôt un parfait
contre exemple c'est l'allemagne
l'allemagne a appliqué la politique
écologique de monsieur depuis dix ans
c'est un nom dix ans plus tard c'est 500
milliards d'euros investis dans les
énergies renouvelables un abandon à 100%
de la filière nucléaire c'est un échec
total il ya un rapport de la cour des
comptes fédéral allemand qui dit en fait
on investit 500 milliards et on a aucune
évolution à la baisse des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre d'allemagne c'est
même pire l'allemagne aujourd'hui pollue
dix fois plus que la france donc on voit
que c'est un échec total
idéologique qui mène nulle part alors
reste un sujet à caution et
effectivement on n'a pas encore une
cellule de fait news sur rt france mais
comme l'allemagne pour lui dix fois plus
vous pouvez vérifier j'ai vérifié car je
suis certain voilà c'est bien un rapport
de la cour des comptes allemands donc
vous pouvez vérifier tout et tout est
sûre en tout cas celle qui fait la
proposition de retirer toutes les
éoliennes du pays c'est la présidente du
rassemblement national marine le pen
écouter
tout mon soutien aux pêcheurs qui
s'opposent courageusement aux éoliennes
en mer élue présidente de la république
je déconstruire est immédiatement les
chantiers éolien à terre et en mer et
supprimerait toute subvention à l'éolien
jean marc governatori ça vous fait
bondir quand même ce genre de
déclaration marine le pen qui raserait
toutes les éoliennes et les retirer
benoit st-amand
et il est notoire que monsieur et madame
le pen sont pas les plus grands écologie
de la planète que ça suppose de
parfaitement connaître le sujet donc
quand on connaît bien le sujet on se
fait que toute source d'énergie a des
avantages et des inconvénients
donc les énergies fossiles elle tue
l'énergie nucléaire allait dangereuse et
effectivement l'éolien parmi les
énergies renouvelables la biomasse la
géothermie le solaire
il est la moins bonne je suis d'accord
l'éolien et celle la plus problématique
des énergies renouvelables cela dit
l'éolien a sa place dans le mix
énergétique
d'autre part il faut qu'on que
l'écologie est un projet de société
complet si en allemagne vous continuez
comme c'est fait depuis 15 ans le
productivisme apte à pouvoir et de
consumérisme à tout va effectivement
vous avez de gros besoins énergétiques
étaient entonnés l'écologiste et
comporte un projet de 7 et écologistes
ça va de pair avec des bottes décision
par exemple faire moins de publicité par
exemple arrêter de compter des centres
commerciaux par exemple réhabiliter des
appartements vacants en france et à
trois millions d'appartements vacants
donc ce n'est pas la peine d'en
construire d'autres y à il ya 10
millions de mètres carrés de bureaux ils
utilisent et qu'on peut transformer
l'appartement il ya beaucoup de sujets
qui peuvent faire que la besoin de
beaucoup moins d'énergie parce que
chaque fois que vous grand frisé quelque
chose vous avez besoin d'énergie donc on
peut bâtir une société écologistes en
prenant des mesures dans leur ensemble
pour avoir besoin de moins d'énergie
aujourd'hui quand vous entendez ce
discours effectivement des écologistes
qui connaissent certainement son sujet
vous répondez quoi aujourd'hui c'est
clairement lors le tout nucléaire pour
vous écoutez moi je n'arrive pas à
savoir si monsieur maîtrise son sujet
parce que déjà il rejoint mon avis sur
la vie d'eric zemmour notamment sur les
éoliennes tu content d'entendre
aujourd'hui je reviens
vous en voulez pas du tout mais en fait
moi je n'en veux pas à pas par principe
je n'en veux pas que ça ne marche pas je
serais ravi de savoir que ça marche ça
ne marche pas donc moi si vous lécher
c'est pragmatique enfin on considère que
ça ne fonctionne pas on voit que ça
n'apporte absolument aucune production
énergétique comptable et surtout il faut
rappeler que c'est une énergie
intermittente une éolienne fonctionne 21
% de son activité sur la question du
nucléaire vous avez un fonctionnement à
100% ça fonctionne tous les jours de
l'année ensuite sur l'éolien vous êtes
dépendant du climat vous êtes dépendant
des métaux et donc des vents vous avez
un double un double défaut et sur les
questions des besoins énergétiques je ne
suis toujours pas d'accord avec monsieur
on voit bien qu'on est en train
d'électrifier aujourd'hui tous nos
moyens de transport c'est les voitures
c'est les vélos les trottinettes les
avions les bateaux donc sur ces 2 - dans
l'énergie et je ne parle même pas des
grandes entreprises qui existe qui
seront aussi elle toujours plus
gourmandes en énergie en énergie
électrique on est à une demande qui est
colossal cette demande on a les moyens
d'y répondre avec une filière
extraordinaire qu'on maîtrise
parfaitement france on peut en être fier
et je crois que les français sont plutôt
fiers c'est la troisième filiale
industrielle française est donc
aujourd'hui cette technologie est là
répond à tous les besoins énergétiques
d'aujourd'hui de demain j'irai même plus
loin on est même on a été excédentaire
en production électrique et on a exporté
c'est vous dire à quel point aujourd'hui
c'est une technologie dont on a besoin
et surtout qu'on doit encourager
d'abord préciser que le réseau action
climat est l'instance suprême en termes
d'environnement et de climat dans notre
pays puisqu'elle rassemble la fondation
nicolas hulot agir pour l'environnement
vf avec la sema liste régionale est la
plus performante en terme de projet pour
le team a donc vous connais parfaitement
le sujet donc je répète que tout les
taux d'énergie ont des avantages et des
inconvénients le nucléaire au delà du
danger qu'ils représentent
ignorant 100% dépendant de l'extérieur
c'est un vrai problème c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi les écologistes en pièces que
je représente le soir sont défavorables
à la voiture électrique qui est un fléau
écologique un fléau main est un fléau
financiers et géopolitiques puisque là
aussi ces périodes où une voiture
électrique
grassement effectivement les bonus sur
les voitures électriques et pénalise les
autres
elle est aussi problématique la voiture
thermique donc on peut tout à fait
limité largement le besoin du nucléaire
les quelques mesures petit à l'heure
mais qui soit bien clair que toutes ses
énergies à des avantages inconvénients
mais si on reste sur une société
énergivore effectivement on va continuer
d'aller vers l'impasse et je rappelle à
monsieur que six succès selon les zones
que l'éolien est productif à 25% du
temps où 50% du temps où 70% du temps
sur le réseau mais c'est pareil pour le
nucléaire et repasse pour le pet les
énergies territoire que à cause de la
problématiques liées à une technologie
très poussée il ya une temps 30% des
centrales hier qu'ils ne meurent en
tiennent pas en france donc la france
obtient aujourd'hui sur les deux tiers
des centrales nucléaires donc il faut
pas croire que terre la centrale
nucléaire marche c'est exact ce n'est
pas une énergie intermittente sauf que
le tir le tiers ou 30% des centrales
nucléaires ne fonctionne pas parce qu'il
ya des problèmes technologiques liés à
cette propre énergie arthur paraissiez
vous est ce qu il ya une autre
alternative que l'éolien pour réduire la
part du nucléaire dans notre
consommation énergétique
écouter aujourd'hui déjà pourquoi se
poser la question de la réduction de la
part du nucléaire si nucléaires
fonctionnent si le nucléaire est
performant et je le dis ça va agacer
monsieur surtout cynique les attendait
pas mais parle effectivement
c'est nucléaire et écologique parce que
c'est une énergie décarbonée aujourd'hui
la france il faut le rappeler le mix
énergétique français à 90 % à 90 % ont
produit d'énergie propre décarbonés à
100% donc c'est à dire un mix de
barrages hydroélectriques et de
nucléaire donc la france n'a pas à
rougir elle produit aujourd'hui son
électricité de manière 100% verte 90% et
si on n'est qu'à 90% ce parce que la
politique notamment que promeut monsieur
nous a considérablement affaibli la
filière du nucléaire donc moi je vois
pas pourquoi pourrait se poser la
question déjà d'affaiblir ou de sortir
d'une technologie qui marche je rappelle
l'exemple de l'allemagne qui en est
sorti à 100 % à l'horizon 2022 et qui
dit c'est un échec total la cour des
comptes dit c'est un échec cuisant ces
500 milliards jetés à la poubelle donc
et je reviendrai sur un dernier point ça
nous rend de surcroît indépendant et non
pas dépendant de l'extérieur parce que
aujourd'hui la source qui permet de
produire le nucléaire on la trouve à peu
près partout dans les différents pays
dans le monde dont l'autre russie
notamment dans les océans
donc en plus il ya des enjeux de
souveraineté d'indépendance alors que
quand monsieur veut faire importer des
pales éoliennes et qui ne produisent
rien qui fonctionne 20% de l'année quand
ensuite en viennent de chine ensuite
vous les renvoyer en afrique ou en
france ou ailleurs pour les enfouir je
ne comprends franchement je ne comprends
pas l'écologie qu'il ya derrière ça et
donc pour moi oui
proposition d'eric zemmour 6 une
proposition écologique mais encore
faut-il être capable de l'entendre sur
les chiffres et j'aimerais citer jean
marc jancovici qui est quand même une
personne de référence sur ces questions
là qu'elle crée un think tank de conseil
aujourd'hui il le dit de manière très
sérieuse il est pro nucléaire il est pro
nucléaire parce que les chiffres sont
avec le nucléaire
le mot de la fin pour vous et jean marc
governatori 8000 éoliennes aujourd'hui
sur le territoire la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie aie prévoit
elle qui a donné 20 milles d'ici 2028
qu'est-ce qui vous évoque ce chien c'est
une folie puisque coûte aujourd'hui
l'électricité en france est peut être à
productivité d'une éolienne
la réponse aux besoins énergétiques de
notre pays c'est d'une part limitée de
productivisme et limiter le groupe
imerys mme temps par exemple ou limiter
la publicité à babu limiter les besoins
en énergie d'autre part l'éducation à
l'environnement d'autre part isoler
toute construction parce qu'en plus ça
crée des emplois qui sont longues balles
et colisable et quand nucléaire nous
avons le devoir d récupère sa part être
de notre dépendance parce que l'uranium
nous l'important est par ailleurs lu
nucléaire a besoin de beaucoup d'eau et
il n'a échappé à personne que nous
connaîtrons des deux chefs de sécheresse
et donc c'est un vrai problème ce besoin
de dos une claire ils ne sont pas
nucléaire ne peut pas survivre sans eau
est donc sacré encore une problématique
parce qu'effectivement il peut y avoir
des engins nucléaires qui ne fonctionne
plus justement parce qu'avant il n'y a
pas d'autre parce que c'est là cherchent
leur s par conséquent il faut faire un
mix énergétique avec la géothermie la
biomasse le solaire de l'éolien est
évidemment l'éducation l'environnement
et l'isolation merci en tout cas tous
les deux jean marc governatori d'avoir
été avec nous en direct arthur paris sur
ce plateau merci à vous
et direction marseille à présent où la
grève des éboueurs ce poursuit les
poubelles ne cesse de déborder depuis
dix jours ces travailleurs s'oppose à la
loi sur la réforme de la fonction
publique un texte qui prévoit
l'alignement de tous les agents aux 35
heures hebdomadaires à partir de janvier
prochain reportage en place d'isabelle
ferrières et nicolas petit
dans le centre de marseille
la scène se répète les poubelles
s'entassent et déborde sur la chaussée
tout comme la cgt force ouvrière
syndicat majoritaire des agents de la
métropole aix-marseille rejette les
nouvelles conditions de travail avec le
passage aux 35 heures généralisée dans
la fonction publique en fait on nous
propose autres 28 journées
supplémentaires pour pas un euro de plus
je sais pas le salarié un brin ce qui
pour accepter de telles conditions il
faut carrément comptabiliser le temps de
travail non pas à un jour ou une semaine
mais un temps de travail annualisé
puisque nous avons des sites où les
éboueurs travail 365 jours par an c'est
à dire que en fait il n'ya pas de ferrié
il n'y a pas de dimanche et durs sont
comptabilisés comme un des jours de
travail normal et ça nous disons c'est
pas prochain bloc après l'échec lundi
des négociations sur le temps de travail
des éboueurs qui doit augmenter avec la
loi de la fonction publique territoriale
les dépôts de la métropole compte 90 %
de grévistes le bras de fer ne fait donc
que commencer les riverains sont
pourtant à bout je sais pas pourquoi ça
serait plus pénible que beaucoup
d'autres métiers moi que je connais
peut-être la décompensation
à envisager mais en tout cas pas laisser
les marseillais et tous les touristes et
tout les personnes habitant ici dans des
conditions de saleté de malpropreté
l'odeur insupportable
généralement il ya quelques poubelles
qui prennent feu qui convolent et
quelques véhicules autour on est presque
habitués
je suis ça c'est dramatique ça part tout
part dans la mer à la fin c autre
productif et c'est par sa portée il ya
les rades partout bien sûr mais ça on
est habitué aussi à marseille les
habitants ont depuis 2015 et à
l'exception de 2018 connu au moins une
grève des éboueurs par an
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi rendez vous demain pour un
nouveau numéro en attendant l'actualité
continue toute la soirée sur rtl france
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
vous avez assisté à cette fabrication
d'une machine terroriste de l'est